okay so yeah so over the last two
lectures we were talking about
electrical flows and optimization and
maximum flow problem and well today we
finally do some real work and actually
solve something exactly and correctly
right
so just in case you just tuned in we are
solving the maximum flow problem and
what the definition is as usual nothing
changed since this is the morning so we
are trying to find a feasible SD flow of
Maximum value so we just want to have
the we just want to look visible as the
flow is the one that specifies the
localization constraints and does all
different arcs and you want to maximize
value okay that's still the same problem
you want to solve
and today yes I finally will talk about
the result that shows us that actually
we can you know we are breaking this
entire Treehouse barrier in more and
more than our scenarios and now we are
just break it in the scenario when we
have unit capacity and directed graphs
and everything is fine so the only
really constraint healing capacity and
also actually the depends on this
Varsity is not idea so the for non-fast
graphs these boundaries become n becomes
M so there is still something to be
desired but well there's to be boring if
it was if everything was destroyed okay
so this is the result I want to talk
about so let's just get to it
so and again the usual reminder all
capacitor one graph is sparse and we
know the value of Max Pro even though
here it will not matter here we don't
need to know the value of mass
okay so the obvious question you know
after this two hours of lectures I'm
sorry the lecture in the morning is you
know that's what also mesh asks you know
why and we you have such a wonderful
progress on the approximately and
directed regime now why are we not done
it's like why we can't just take this
machinery and just apply it to the
electric case and be done okay
so well tempting answer would be well
this is about we are dealing here with
the graphs if the graphs are of course
different than on directly graphs and in
particular crucially
electrical flows are an addicted notion
is that this was crucial that the
Android uh that the max electrical flows
we always compute in the context of
unbelievable okay that's very crucial
so that's a tempting answer but it's not
the right answer and you know the reason
why this is not the right and when I
answered the two answers right I will
just focus on one of them which is very
specific to Max flow namely Max flow has
this very interesting feature that you
can you can reduce the exact direct Max
flow so computation of exact unlikely
Works flow so it's really not about
graph being there if you don't know or
not the only thing that's important here
that there is it says exactly the exact
view so essentially once you are able to
solve undirected Maxwell exactly as
opposed to approximately you already get
the direct case for free okay that's
it's really about all it's all about
just getting the sufficient input
dependence of our running time on
accuracy Okay so
so that's the reason end of the game and
once you realize that when you look back
at what we have done in the for the
native Max flow so roughly at the very
high level what we are doing is we just
have this electrical flow Oracle and
then we you know we just use it to
interact with our infograph to probe its
structure by computer electrical flows
and then we use this multiplication
updates routine to sort of put it all
together and get an approximate solution
okay so now if you know that the
accuracy is the key thing the key
bottleneck here that you sort of well
that you would like to go go over you
realize that multiplicative weight
update method is the first order method
so it's like it's a instance of a
gradient descent and it is understood
that you know if you use this kind of
method if you only base your if you
sometimes if you if you only look at the
first order methods and you build your
solution using first order method then
you have to have some you know
polynomial depends on the website okay
there is no way around it okay so if you
like so the obvious thing is that if you
want to have a Hope on let's say log
over on the upside on different
dependence on the error we should allow
you to get exact exact uh in that case
you have to throw it away like this
intermediary is just not powerful enough
this is you know they will not get
anywhere if you if you use that so you
need something new to put it in place
okay so once you realize that then of
course there is a vast optimization
literature and you ask yourself or
you're looking the literature you know
what is the next bigger Hammer you know
what is the hammer that actually goes
beyond first other information about the
function that you are minimizing and
then you will quite quickly find a very
very powerful powerful camera a hammer
called interior Point levels okay in
particular we will be considering the
following variety of them but you know
this is a general notion and you know
this is a real real Hammer okay so
essentially this is you can do it as a
powerful framework for solving not only
linear programs but actually in general
context programs okay so then as you can
extend them to various classes of
complex programs and roughly speaking
the idea you know how they work is just
as follows so imagine that we have so
many year program in this form so we
have mean c the cd.x and you know we
have constraints the equality
constraints so ax equals B but also we
have no negativity constraints and you
can convince yourself that you can cast
NLP in this form okay so we are not
losing anything in generality here and
now do I interrupometer approach solving
such a problem well what they do is that
they look and they don't look it but
conceptually you can look at such an LP
and you see we see that there are two
type of constraints here okay and
surprisingly even though it might not
look like that this ax equals B is the
constraints are easy so it's like
like Boyd is saying he's always saying
that you know this is just linear
algebra okay so you can like if you just
if it was just about ax equal B then
things would be good sort of what makes
this LP heart difficult to solve is this
not the additional negativity
constraints so these are really the hard
constraints here that we sort of need a
new Machinery to to go beyond okay and
so the idea behind terrific method is
just well the basic is just the
following so what you try to do is that
you take care of these hard constraints
in a different way than just enforcing
them explicitly so what you do you just
drop these constraints and instead you
introduce a barrier term to your
objective function okay so this barrier
term essential you can view it as a
certain perturbation of your ordinary so
you drop the constraints and then you
perturb your objective with this term so
it's a sum over I log x i and you know
mu is sort of the extent of this
perturbation and what you can easily see
is that essentially this barrier stem
really enforces that you know whenever
you are inside the feasible region here
so when all the X are negative then it
prevents you from ever like from ever
have any of the X become negative
because the closer you get to the to the
to the x equals zero this term becomes
you know it goes to Infinity so
essentially this it pushes you out of
this of this boundary of the region so
you can and that's in that this is why
this is this term is named earlier
fraction essentially you just sort of
enforces like to penalizes you for
getting too close to the boundary of
your of your feasibility region and this
way you enforce this negative
constraints okay so this is the first
step
and then you ask also it's easy to see
okay so and so so first of all this you
have to trust me on that is that if mu
is large enough so essentially if when
this term takes over like it becomes
more important than our actual objective
function then solving sectional p is
very easy okay it's essentially uh boils
down to finding something called
analytic center of our of of our polytop
okay and this this can be done easily
and the other thing that you can also
notice is that you know as Mu approaches
zero from the positive side then the
optimal solution to our LP mu becomes
close to the optimal solution to the
actual LP you want to solve okay so
essentially all we really are looking
for is the you know the solution to lpmu
for Mu being very close to zero
so these are the observation and once
you have this observation then it's my
already you know you might get a hint
you know how to try to solve such a
problem and what you do is something
called The Path following routine okay
so what you do well you start with some
optimal or near optimal solution to your
lpmu for Big Value of new you can as I
asserted you can get it relatively
easily
and now what you do while you try to
sort of improve uh improve your LPS like
reduce the perturbation okay so what you
just do is that you know given some new
optimal solution to help him you for
some value of mu what you do well you
try to use this solution to well to get
a solution for an LP new for its smaller
so for helping neoprime for a smaller
new product okay roughly speaking what
you can what you are doing is just what
you do is in each step you take your mu
Prime to be one minus Delta times mu for
some small Delta that will be chosen
appropriately and then you use something
called Newton's method to compute a new
optimal solution to LP new crime but
starting from you know from your initial
point being the optimal solution to the
lp meal okay so just a couple of
comments so what is this Newton's method
roughly speaking interest method is just
a way of solving an unconstrained
optimization problem in which you just
assume like sort of your approximate
your actual your actual objective
function which in this case is just C
plus x minus disabled passes barrier
function you are just approximating it
by just looking at the you know it's
second order
setting order a Taylor expansion and
just you know we assume that your actual
function looks like you know it's second
order expansion and then you just solve
you know you just solve it directly once
you you know assume that this is the
function so essentially you can easily
see that here we have this hedging
showing up which is a matrix and
essentially all you really have to do is
just solder your system in this much in
this in this in this case to get you
know the optimal X if F was of this form
okay so we are ignoring everything
beyond that okay so this is what Newton
does there is some projection because we
want to not leave our you know our
constraint space but this is the idea
essentially you just sort of look at the
second order approximation of your
function and and try to optimize it as
opposed to your actual function okay
anyway this is the crucial moment when
we start using second order information
about our objective function okay
okay we're on the face of the grid okay
so this is the this is the this is the
idea and somehow the key Point why it
works is that the Newton method it has
interesting it has an interesting
feature that if your starting point is
sufficiently close of of the optimal
solution to the to your viewers problem
then the convergence of what is
extremely rapid okay
Okay small so we can ensure that our
current solution to the to the the to
the to the linear program LP new is
close enough to the optimal solution to
the uh to the linear program helping
your Prime okay and just so essentially
we want to make sure that our steps are
small enough that we always are in the
radius of Rapid converters of the
neutral's metal okay that depends on the
complexity of properties
it depends on the properties of FPS okay
it actually depends on the local normal
but yes
okay so it is there is well you can we
will try to come up with a number but in
general it depends heavily it depends
essentially on the Haitian and so on
not truly again because the nice thing
is that essentially everything that that
the Haitian is approximating well you
get for free so sort of it actually
depends on the like on the third order
things
depend on the Speculator
no it shouldn't I think the degrading
the same depends on that
like the point is that you know if this
is a good approximation of your function
you will get the optimum right away so
it really depends on the error which is
like in the in the third level
tell you that it should depend on them
maybe there is something I don't know
I'm happy to learn
okay maybe maybe there is like okay what
is for sure true is that if this
approximation is good then you will get
the optimal solution monster okay so the
whole point is that well it's probably
there is some errors that you have to
take care of okay and somehow why this
is called the path following routine but
this is a very nice perceptual picture
so roughly what you should look at is no
matter this is your this is your
feasible region like this is the ax or B
and then this is a red constraint
correspond to impulsive negative
non-economical spray
and then we visit our contactor in our
office lies somewhere here so and you
know the key thing to look at is
something called the central path which
is just a curve that you get by looking
at all the optimal solution to LP new
for all values of mu so as I said when
mu is very big then sort of it well
these solutions they they approach
something called the analytic Center of
this of this obviously of this version
but then you know as the MU gets smaller
and smaller and smaller we are getting
closer and closer to the order okay and
essentially all of these are following
everything is doing is just trying to
follow this curve by just the
approximating discrete steps and of
course the whole idea here is that on
one hand you want to take big steps
because you know you want to have as few
steps as possible but since this thing
can be quite curvy you you don't want
like two big steps so you are lost and
somehow you are losing like so
essentially the point is that as long as
you are close to the central path there
is this relative comparison methods so
you don't want to render to perform but
on that you want to make a big step and
this is the the you know underlying
fundamental attention that you have to
understand to sort of to understand the
complexity of this metal but this is the
whole outline of this network like all
the Performing methods work within this
framework and then the question is you
know how do you take steps and so on and
so on
sorry the path is an attractor yes yes
it would go wrong if you go too far away
from the path well the problem is that
then you lose you lose the rapid
convergence of the nuisance method so
essentially yes you can go back to the
to the central part but it will be too
extensive and somehow like the question
is you know like he wants to like the
question is you know you can take big
steps but then coming back might be so
extensive that taking this big step was
not really beneficial we don't want to
be within the because in the radius of
the quadratic converter
once you are below that then you are in
trouble becomes much much weaker
sorry blue arrows on the scripture steps
of the Newton method sorry are the blue
arrows yes picture on it I guess but yes
that's what I'm doing so essentially
okay it's not the path actually it's a
little bit of artistic artistic
yeah especially here so essentially the
way that we will be doing it so it will
take a step and then we will go back to
the central path and then we will take a
step and go back to set up and say and
so on so actually each arrow is
corresponds to two steps that you know
one of them goes a little bit towards
you know on the tangent of this Etc but
then you go back to the central path and
then you take a step again so I guess my
PowerPoint skills are not strong enough
to really Express that so and also this
is a nicer picture so that's why this is
what you write that actually think is
that we take a step and then we want to
go back to the circle take a step and so
on of course being in the neighborhood
of central office is funny so you don't
have to be exactly so you will never be
on this exactly
that's a good question
it's not the only function of properties
I think there are you know well there
are some like some people consider
different like different buyer function
and because it's all at the end of the
day it's all about you know the curve
like the the curvature of this of the
simple path whatever Central path you
get it will be good as long as you can
you know actually take a Newton step
reverse up to this and uh
flat line from X to opt then it would be
great actually you can imagine some like
polynomial barrier function for high
enough polynomial that will make this
thing very straight but then optimizing
already this is very difficult so there
is some Traders so definitely it's not
clear that log is the the right function
here but somehow people try different
things and block turns out to be usually
the best ways but it's a very good thing
to keep your background money just
thinking how about the different barrier
functions there's definitely like we
know what are the properties that we
need for this to work but log is not the
only the only function that created
okay another questions
okay
so this is the terminal outline engineer
ones we have this Hammer so let's try
some some something simple and well
after all Max flow definitely can be
casted as an LP so how about asking a
maximum just solidity amazing method so
maybe this will allow us to just get
down very quickly okay so maybe the
whole problem that you just didn't
I just didn't know in the optimization
okay so of course if you ask someone
about that to enter the conventional
business we just say that this will be
too slow okay and the reason why this
will be too slow is that essentially
well we have to take this neutrons
better and as I said it corresponds to
solving to in your system
hopefully something super quadratic so
you're just taking one step takes over
the superclotting time then whereas
there is a hope to beat a endless we
have to already you're already done by
the time you make you take the first
step however you know this is however
this is
observices
that actually when you look at the
information of the max row and you look
at the linear systems that are there
they essentially first come to labels
and systems okay and for these things we
actually know as algorithms and we can
Implement each of the Newton steps
include the New England time okay so
that's a very good news because now the
only question that remains is okay so we
know that each step you can take it in
new your time it's the fastest way
and hope for so the question is how many
iterations do we need before we convert
close to Optimal solution and of course
this is a very well stated question and
this because it's a fundamental question
here reputable method and renegar showed
in 1988 that this bounty is current
event okay so roughly the convergence
rate is roughly square root of n okay so
putting this all together what you get
well you get in yet another and to the
three cups are good for much so so you
know so so that is really something
annoying about this treehouse that it
shows up over and over okay and well
what can we do now well we can
definitely improve the running time of
information so the only hope would be to
improve this this upper body and you
know there is some hope for it because
no one believes that this is right now
okay no you believe this is the right
bank but unfortunately you know there is
also no proof that you can do better
okay so this is one of the uh questions
in your program in case like how to
improve when you're just being on this
score
sorry are there any loan pounds
I think there are some other ones I
think the the current candidate is empty
one third this is the right thing and
there are some construction like I I
Frankly Speaking I didn't follow the
slower but you know as long as they
don't prove anything on how I I I'm not
that interested like there are some very
like the linear programs that they're
using that are very strange that's of
course they just serve the purposes they
just fix that the way they prove it of
course it is they fix their variation of
the entire product because you know this
is just a different thing
there's a lot of things so they just
choose one and for this one they create
a program that makes it a little bit
like we start off showing that same
place yeah exactly this is exactly the
same important yeah so it is but I think
that even in here it's even less of
agreement which is there yeah I guess
the same before sometimes
yes
no no no do you mean this lower bands
for simple experience
[Music]
and of course again in practice is very
fast the practice is very fast like you
know you don't really approach like
there is nobody here
so essentially like when you look at
when you look at what you get like
what's a linear system that you get when
you know that your Matrix a is actually
the metric that sort of checks the flow
conservation constraints when you look
at the Matrix algebraically it has not
to be essentially The Flash so once you
project your yeah so essentially so once
you project you just have to solve the
lesson system at least we can do things
yes so
it seems it depends on the property it
has here you know the patience is simple
if it's just one over excellent square
but then you have to take a projection
on the space on the Kernel and then
that's where when you write this
production it turns out to be a version
it was B transpose the AI console so
okay
so I'll just look second
[Music]
that's where
okay
just because like the very functioning
separable functions like essentially
just so there's like there's no objects
just never under everything okay okay
so it looks like it again but you know
let's let us leave it like that and just
try to get something anyways okay and
what I will actually do I will present
you an algorithm so there is a question
from Luca who asks his little laplacian
system that gives you the interior
points that's the same one as the
electrical flow is it electrical
spoiling surprises yes
the sporting supplies us here so
essentially what will happen is that I
will give you a self-contained algorithm
but at the end of the day what we will
be doing to be exactly in particular
flows will I will not say it explicitly
too many times but essentially
electrical flows are exactly the
neutrons it's essentially like you can
forget all these room methods now there
will be just if you forget about the
just strange thing called centrality
that will show up as simple but other
than that like it's really a simple
technology
to solve the problem about really what
he's doing and this is the way I
discovered this is that you know I I was
I got very fed up with the momentum
because I realized that I don't really
understand that so then I just
this this guy develop the algorithm of
my own and then realize that's oh that's
what they did so that's the way like
social effects for me that was the way
to understand what should happen to them
but just seeing how it plays out in the
max flow and then realized that okay
yeah actually I didn't do anything to do
this like all that I did can be
translated about
and that's super funny but in particular
indeed the African flows are exactly
corresponds to to this projections right
yeah exactly these are exactly
or something
okay so just let's just this is just one
one side of the setup so essentially
instead of
following the max flow problem what I
will actually do I will reduce it to
certain version of an uncapacitated mean
cost flow okay and this mean console is
a sigma flow when you can actually allow
myself to help architect demons and
practices okay so instead of having just
an smt and then every all the other all
the other vertices just having two weeks
now I actually just set up a pattern of
the amount like
different matrices and I just you know I
just look at four Sigma so any flow that
has exactly this pattern of the months
and circles
okay
and again now I can forget our
capacities and the only thing that now I
have caused and a lot you can think
about cost being one they will not
change over they will not change
anything but way over there I'm trying
to get rid of directed it no I'm not
getting rid of digital Edge upgrade
which is very important by not getting
rid of
there so no so I'm not getting it just
things are still directed and actually
it should be the crucial thing like this
is the second instead of the negativity
constraints that are the most difficult
parts of Russian this is something that
we definitely can't just build up to
because we need okay and somehow you
know why did we do it so one one reason
why we do this is that Maxwell is
essentially a feasibility question at
least in in general form so we want to
change into an optimization question so
now we'll just randomize this on cost on
my overflow and also you know we get
such a section bill has to worry about
capacities and also relational
additional things that will come up like
okay so but the only point the toxicity
so here is that there's no capacities
now the only thing that you have to
enforce is that there is no negativity
of the flows on the arcs which are
directed and now the demands can be
arbitrary as opposed to just
okay
so now we will solve this mean because
the sigma flow instance and this will be
a timer developer okay so what we will
what will happen we will just maintain a
primer and do our feasible Solutions and
then we will sort of try to modify both
of them to reduce The Duality that which
is sort of the lower Partners objectify
you given by dual solution and and the
what the upper bound on the objective
value given by the time okay so let's
just take a moment and think you know
what are the primary dual feasible so we
should look like in this case so for the
previous solution this is easy
essentially any Sigma flow so any flow
that preserves the demo is given by the
sigma that also has you know all the
flows on Earth is interactive so it
doesn't flow the other way on directors
arcs then any such flow is a physical a
feasible private solution okay so what
is the Dual solution it's just a
slightly and just a slightly more
complicated so essentially Your solution
corresponds to embedding of our graph in
the line okay and our feasibility
position is roughly that we don't
stretch our arms too much okay so what
I'm talking about is does the following
say imagine we have an arc that goes
from U to V and here is its embedding
into the line given by this numbers y u
and Y and then what we really want we
want that you know if I look at the
embedding of the tail and depending of
the head and the embedding of the head
should not be further to the right to
the embedding of the tail than the cause
of the arc okay so essentially the way I
can specify that I can look I can look
at this slack as the difference between
how far this can go to the right and and
how far it is to the right and this
would be the slack and I just have to
enforce that the slack is always no
negative okay so by the way going to the
left of the head you can go as far as
you want it's all about just going to
the right you can't you can't get
stretched to the right too much okay so
this is the Dual physical condition and
we will always maintain a you know a
sigma Pro F and and when you point that
correct that preserve the specificity
conditions we always maintain them and
then we know that the essentially what
we what we know then is that we want to
minimize the video article so now when
you compute the difference between the
upper button on the object given by the
summer solution and the lower back on
the objective given by one solution then
it conveniently ends up being just this
expression so this is some overall edges
the flow on the edge times its lap okay
so essentially again you have nice
separable formula for like each Edge
contributes to dual article this product
is
I'm going to show the graph is just an
arbitrary graph or it looks like it's by
part-time yeah
I would just wave my hands how we use it
towards the end like so yeah it has
something I think at this point you
should think about the officials like
this is something like a like software
that you would get from like a relaxing
back punching and so just taking my
friend to the graph and you know taking
okay so they all look like that that you
take a Barbacoa graph you you order
everything from left to right and then
you just add such a star with you know
a vector and sorry vertex and you just
add the Arts both ways from it to every
other vertex okay so this is exactly the
kind of piece you should have in mind
this is no Supply no demand surprising
demands are humans but the guy in the
middle yeah excuse you where are the
cost how's that all one think about them
all being one and the batted edges are
free or not no no this is bi-directional
interest they also one the capacity is
also there's no capacities problem
the ones appear like in the objective
right so you know when you take the Dual
then the the right the right hand sum of
the constraints becomes the ready object
is suppressed so this is nice that you
know once you look at the slab it's very
clean you don't really don't have this
you don't have to resistance
wise it's just an embedding connection
let's do our solution embedding of the
vertices into the light so if I have y
is then I can compute the stack so
okay what's my voltages but they're not
they will be ready to go to this yes
just let's in general they don't have to
but we they will be will build a lot of
voltages yes indeed that's a good
analysis so for flow we have a close
limit voltages
so are you solving the Min cost Max flow
in general or with this special
structure
that's very important I would like to
but I can't oh okay so this is
understanding this particular instance
of it this matter of type of instances
and what's special about it is this
special vertex that yeah
like I don't want to go too much into
this like they showed up earlier and I
don't even talk about this much but you
know there is something about the
structure that is very important
particularly what's important is that I
can get from any vertex in the vertex by
a path of pleasure okay that's actually
right that's why I added essential I see
okay
so so these edges are directed in both
ways
okay but this this one over here are not
there only from left one
okay
so yeah so we want to uh so we want to
essentially our goal as you know every
pyramidal algorithm we just want to
reduce Duality Gap and actually we will
make our life a bit harder and
essentially we will want to to reduce
Duality Gap while the forcing additional
constraint okay and this constraint is
centrality and then maybe what you want
also to have
you want to ensure that at any point of
time the contribution of each acid
Duality Gap is roughly the same okay so
that we are reducing this contribution
of
each Edge in a uniform way okay so so we
are making our life harder here because
for parallel framework we just need to
reduce the sum but actually we want not
only reduce the sample also want to
reduce the new uniform way that all the
that all the contributions of each Edge
are going down in the same rate so this
uses a suggestive choice or adjustable
it is it is suggestive choice so
essentially if you look back at what the
meal was in the biofractor is exactly
the same you and what this condition
really means I think I yes material
condition is that mechanic similarity
that's meaning following central part so
whenever I it is the case that all the
products are exactly new it means that I
am at the same and it's optimal solution
for LP so yes definitely the choice
okay so that's so special for this
specific barrier function yes it's
foreign
that's that's the crucial point so
that's if you think about this as a
parallel algorithm this is the this is
the strange part it's like why would I
enforce this thing and well the
motivation comes exactly for Interval
method that's that you want to be close
to Central path but you know this will
manifest itself in some way but again
for the same reason that it does
saying the automatic conditions that
those fese is equal to
yes yes this is documentation like if I
have s-e-s-e for the same meal for all
the for all the address it needed your
Optical solution
so so that's that's our goal so question
is now you know everything is is very
similar so questions you know how can we
actually improve our resources if I have
a timer how I improve it
okay and of course not surprisingly they
ask who you usually but again this is
this exactly will be the neutral steps
that we are taking essentially since we
are maintaining the centrality then we
want to like we will take a stereo
system it should be a neutral step and
then you sort of always want to make
sure that you are close to the well that
you are close to yourself so this is
exactly like we're really intimidating
here without saying the situation
okay
so how will we will do that so imagine
we have our current premium dual
solution and what we will do the key
step here is that we will compute an
electrical Sigma flow
with resistances given by like
resistance of an edge being SE over F so
know that when I compute the cylindrical
flow I disregard the directions okay so
even though the underlying graph is
directed when a computer can flow I
forget about the directions and I allow
the flow can go you know even the wrong
direction I it's fine okay I allow my
antenna flow to to that's that's very
important that's one more reason why how
you can throw like why you can be able
to use undirected electrical flows to
solve the type of problem essentially
you will see that it will come out but
sort of local you can treat them as a as
another one so what's the interpretation
of the sigma in the electrical problem
like it just you're just optimized now
so so what is electrical flow is just
you minimize over all the flows with you
know with with the deficit of F at you
know at the source and surface of F at
the sink and then zero everywhere else
so you minimize energy over all such
flows so here is just extended
differently so now you mean
is
foreign
okay
so now once we compute the cellular we
want to use it to update our solution so
we have to do a primary Improvement
instead and what we do is actually
something something very very natural so
we just take you know we just take a
mixing of our current solution you know
with a great one minus Delta and then we
mix in a Delta of the centrical flow so
clearly since I took a convex
combination I'm still getting a sigma
flow of the time okay and then what I
would have to argue about feasibility
but let's let's give it to that and now
what is the Dual Improvement what is
going to Improvement of course you know
we can't add flow to the embedding but
of course now we have Alternatives okay
so what we will just do we'll just use
voltages that are using this electrical
Flow by also to update our dual
Solutions what we do is that we take our
own dual solution and then we add this
Factor graphic Delta times you know the
voltage is given by the given by Direct
Cash Flow okay and that's our dual
updates
and you know so why does it work so you
know one crucial thing about this
updates that is just the following is
that if I look now you know after I
updated my Prime manual solution when I
look at the corresponding contribution
of an edge to the to the dividing after
this update and if I ignore all the
terms that are depending product number
and our magic happens
again but magic happens and what happens
is that actually my new new Prime is
just one minus Delta times U so notice
that this does not depend on the edge so
what it just shows is that the
contribution of each of each of each
Edge to The Duality Gap just goes down
at the same rate
okay so clearly if we're able to just
really disregard this quadratic terms of
Delta then well that's it essentially
you just you just keep doing that and
you will be you will have amazing like
ideal centrality in each step and just
you know you just did some sufficiently
large number of steps to get it all the
way down to close to zero
okay and you know this is all nice and
good and driven by the way during the
one that this is true is just exactly by
the way just set up you know that's an
interesting right little step it gets
the linear times right is because it
approximates our function up to
quadratic 10 and for that it solves it
exactly so the only thing that that can
show up only from later in details
seriously that's what is manifested by
this
so as long as you can ignore them
everything is you know everything is
same as ignoring the need for return to
the Republic yes that's exactly the one
yes so so if we could if that's exactly
if you ignore this like if we understand
we're in there then we will just
maintain some practice we will be
exactly following the uh
the central path was given by some
polynomial of like some quadratic
synthetic curve then you know then
Mutual step with the essentially four
weight in one step
but of course it's not it's a much much
more complex curve so then there are
this that's exactly like when we try to
have a quality approximation of our
local product approximation of our curve
you know that's where it really is so if
you ignore the the fragrance
this is not these two things I'd love to
see okay
yes the resistance would be high and
then B squared over R will be also low
right so if that is a little F time will
also be sort of low
uh yes well it depends will be fairly
low also right not really yes because
this this F class can be can have a very
big flow on this particular yes there's
no upper bundle how much flow is on
there so it might be so so huge flow
that you know even after multiplying by
Delta it's still a changes
so you just get B squared over divided
by R right
the power company okay yes so
V square is fixed I mean the potentials
are fixed by Delta right
quotations
Sigma flow means that you like that your
flow has the right demonstruct your
respect the demands yes
yes yes
it just says you know now we have
multiple sources and multiple multiple
things but it just tells you how much
flow is flowing through which
so actually and the same is true for for
this thing what might happen is that
this flow flows in the other direction
but it's supposed to so again if you
take too big data you may end up losing
feasibility because you start F Prime
will start flowing a little bit okay but
so but in general like you know after
this slide what should be clear that all
that we really want to try to understand
is how big Delta can we take so this
approximation makes sense and also we
don't do not lose visibility actually
what is happening is that maintaining
this condition is stronger than with any
visibility so you can show me that if
you maintain this then implicitly you
already with the increasability so you
are not taking too much yeah if you take
electronic Delta you could break
feasibility in both cases so you have to
Also regarding that but you know that's
proving this is already sufficient
because if you have to be close to a
central part it means that together that
you have to be far away from the
boundaries of your physics so this is
clear history okay and that's what you
already have what I have to focus on and
roughly and this is something that I
will just cut short so once you do some
math and also there's another correction
step that I'm just skipping now but
essentially what you can if you ask
yourself you know how big Delta can you
take to not wander off too far from the
central path any particular not to
violate feasibility then essentially
what you get is that you know your
Universe of Delta should be roughly L4
null of a vector row when Vector row is
at the following just you can just think
of it as the volume so you have your
graph okay and you have your current
solution and you think of the flow in
your current solution as being
capacities of the graph okay and now you
are Computing an electrical flow in this
graph and you ask yourself you know how
much this analytical flow is overflowing
its capacity impulse like that so you
can think about this as a congestion
background of the electrical flow f plus
with respects given by the current
solution
so you can just think about this you
know this this Vector row and this Alpha
number row is just measuring how
different electrical flow is to our
common solution okay so that's how I
heard this you just have to take our own
figure this is what you want to get and
now the only thing that remains okay so
we know how big Delta we can do it's
just governed by this Alpha Norm of this
Vector the question so how can we bound
this Alpha Norm to get some you know
absolute bounds so for normal is it is
exactly the quantity of care about our
time it's exactly actually it's exactly
well again you can talk about the flying
but according to your current state of
knowledge this is the best you can like
the best part that you can post I think
this is
okay do you notice oh
because I was asking if you know the two
Norm of uh
well who who wants to bang health or not
how about Humanity because
we can always
that sounds easier so let's just think
about public health okay we can
definitely feel like whatever
so everything is nice okay
so now how can we you know how can we
bound the L to normal a second it's not
really clear but now actually is the
moment where the centrality comes back
okay so for now we just it was a pain
for us to to maintain this entirety but
now is the moment when you pay the pay
start because what it allows us to do is
allows us to tie this and more to the
energy of the electrical flow energy is
something we can't reason about as
opposed to this Vector okay so how how
does it work so we know we know that
instant use of centrality we know that
this product is always roughly roughing
you okay so this is what it gives us
once we work out our resistances which
are SC over Fe it means that each
resistance is roughly new over FD
squared okay so essentially again there
is intuition that F issues you think
about them as a capacity in our ground
so so like SP over squared like divided
by F of just the right is the right is
scaling of each term or resistance is to
make sure that's also for the condition
the heads the right way okay so this we
know that the service is once we have
sativity and because of that we can show
that the energy of the electrical flow
is roughly proportional to the new well
l21 squared of Rhode why well this is
just a simple arithm so what is the
energy of the flow you just sum over all
edges resistance of the edge times the
flow square but we know what resistance
resistances are and we have this FP
squared term here we just you know we
can hide it under the square so we have
sum of our address mu times the exactly
what this is the congestion Vector
Square so what you get is exactly that
this is exactly you know mu minus the
alpha model Square
so this is a great viewers because
founding energy of electrical flow is
something that we can do okay and you
know and how we know how can we bomb
this energy and again this is if I had
time in the morning to give the proof
that I have skipped you would already
know how to do it but we'll do it anyway
now so how can we what happened without
this energy and there is a very easy but
very powerful argumentative essentially
this you just repeat something as well
so I claim that this energy is never
bigger than New Times test okay so how
to show that well what I will do instead
of trying to bound the energy of the
centrica flow directly
instead the energy of some difference in
my flow okay remain our current solution
what is the energy of our current
solution F Well it's sum over overall
edges resistance times different squared
but what are the resistances there are
mu over F squared so here I just get all
one's Vector I get Once in each of these
components so there is n of them and the
angles get new times okay so this is the
energy of the kind solution but how can
I now infer something about the energy
of electrical flow
and ideas
energy
and from that once you unwell all we did
what you get in the end is roughly a
square root of M bound on the inverse of
Delta so what we just really did here is
essentially we recover this canonical
square root of M bound of random RQ okay
and actually this argument you know all
that I said is just algebraic
expressions and if you just put it back
in the general table like it makes sense
in for generalizes and what you what you
have just done here is essentially you
know redirect it in different way the
argument of religion of how to or how to
get the scripture
yeah sorry so somewhere in here you made
the transition to undirected flaws and
this is something more about how that
happened this happened somehow it's
again something I told you during the
translation is that it is hidden here so
I just said if I take steps small enough
I will be fine and in particular I will
not lose visibility like if I take it
more to snap so essentially what I did
is I said like one thing that implicitly
decentrality and forces is that I have
non-zero flow on every Arc and also this
touch is non-zero and now what I'm
saying is that now I am computing
you are getting here is that you are
able to so sort of you know like by
scaling things like to do by keeping
this buyer far enough you're always
actually symmetize your problem and take
a look at undirected and this is the
crucial thing that's the point one we
can use undirected max flow to something
like this it's just it's actually like
being careful about always keeping fire
away from the Thunder Ridge okay and
then taking small enough said that even
if
this is using somehow the special stuff
okay
good
so you know we
great job you know we again and we did
all this work and we got one second and
two and three halves algorithm okay so
we're going to get frustrated
actually I wasn't because I knew like
personally I thought I knew what is the
problem because you already you know
what you know what happened for the
elevated case that's not otherwise it
would be very frustrating so but yeah so
how did you know beyond this world of
intuition environment okay so you know
let's just look back at our reasoning
video all that we did yes so we just use
it in a point we knew that you know that
Universe of that is supposed L for Norm
of row then we use the L2 to L to bound
into boundary for no let me show that L2
Norm is
actually so if you are losing using only
l21 which is what mainly interior
formative papers do there's no hope for
getting Beyond scope okay because it's
not true like this Vector can
consistently be close
so there's only one hope here this you
know try to play with this inequality
here and of course the crucial question
is when is this inequality time so when
is L for null on a vector close to the
l21 okay
only one complement
yes
so like when these things are closed
they are only when the norm of row is
contributed you know by very few
coordinates actually one or like few
chords okay so now the question is oh
okay so we know that when things go bad
so you know so okay this is to our
settings digital twice I think it just
means that you know the things go back
so there are arcs that contribute most
of the energy okay that's exactly what
it means in our language so is it good
or is it bad well it's bad because you
know this actually can happen right and
we already have seen examples when did
exactly this kind of phenomena happens
that there is one Arc that contributes
most of the energy okay so in this sense
you know
okay so essentially there can be bad
steps and but I will talk about more
about this but essentially this can
happen but again you know we know what
to do at least we know what we did in
the united case so what we do is you
know we try to ensure that if it happens
it doesn't happen too often okay and
that's sort of the philosophically you
know that's that's you know if I just
gave it that you know that should be the
end of this topic and unfortunately the
the industry is a bit technical so I
will just say a little bit about it but
not too much because you know what we in
the end do we just apply a very careful
perturbation
and this is the moment
when we really
when we really use the structure of the
flow and of our instances in fact we are
selling Maxwell and the fact that we
that we that we are using capacity so
everything up to now is true for General
at least this is the moment
when you know when things when things
require you know when you really have to
dig into the structure to make the
argument work okay so let me just say a
little bit about you know what's
happening here so again the problematic
case is you know when most of the energy
of our our electrical flow is
contributed by only if you are okay so
how can we ensure that result okay so
yeah we have similar problems in a
relative case and what we did there well
we just signal we just kept removing
this highly high energy edges okay and
then we showed uh you know that to show
that it's worked we just use the energy
potential to show that it can't happen
too often because energy is going
growing growing growing and it can't
grow too much so no period so this was
all nice and and impeaching there but
you know the problem is that you know
that
afford to do this in our framework right
we want to compute our our flow exactly
so we're just removing edges left and
right it doesn't seem like a certificate
an exactly exactly so and also they even
more significant problem is that in our
case so previously we use uh energy as a
potential and nice thing about the
energy then was that it was only Globe
okay so because we're only increasing
resistances of the edges now it's not
not true at all now from step to step
energy can go down or after or down
there is no like nothing that we can
really say about you know how like what
is the behavior so no suddenly it just
becomes a very awful potential energy
because it doesn't go in One Direction
okay so even though the security seems
to be right you know sort of the when
you look at the actual what's happening
this doesn't seem to fit
okay so how to do this problem so one
thing is that you know first we have to
get good potential so what we do is
actually instead of just enforcing a
condition that this L4 Norm is strong it
is small what we ask for something
stronger some kind of smoothness
condition that I so today we try to
rescue the whole spectrum of energy
contribution of edges and the reason why
we do this is that once we enforce that
our flows that we that we use are smooth
then the energy does not change too much
anymore and so it becomes a good
location function now okay but so we
have to enforce more but what we get in
return is that we get a potential
function okay and now you know the way
we enforce this condition is that
essentially whenever we see some some
arcs that offend this condition we just
perturb them and the way we pertain them
is not by removing it but just by
increasing the length of the like so we
are changing the address so we're
increasing the length of the arc by by
their slack and because of that this
results in doubling the resistance
Association instead of removing parts we
just are doubling the resistors okay
whenever we don't like to put some
artists do we just double existence then
we can be recorded okay
and uh you know and it's still the same
still very good of course the resistance
to Infinity yeah well the speed is
definitely very similar unfortunately we
have to be much more careful about stuff
right but yes I agree that's why I was
talking about this other resulting only
because it's so conceptually it gives
you most of the ideas already
and you know one nice thing is about
that you know as long as this
perturbation are small so as long as the
SE small then we just pertain the cost
of our in our solution just by a little
bit so once we get some solution in the
end you can correct you know in the
discrepancy but relatively to be and
sometimes this is still fine so as long
as the bad arcs have small stretch
everything is fine unfortunately you
know all acts have to be to have to have
small success so how to how to deal with
address
so rapid observation here just the
following is that you know one thing
that you can tell say about the Azure
student that you see is that you know
since this is how the resistance is
going and we know that like if SE is Big
it means that the resistance is big as
well okay and now once you look at Edge
that has big resistance and you know if
you ask yourself what does it mean that
this ad that is R contributes a lot of
energy what it means is it also has a
high effective resistance okay so
resistance are different things so if I
have an arc that has
is capturing
and then what you essentially do to fix
that you precondition your solution in
such a way that there is no Arc in your
graph in your solution that has larger
effective resistance okay so essentially
the way you do it is that if this is
your solution what you do is just add
another sort of star graph here that
somehow like there are some technical
things that you have to do but the idea
is essentially you are adding additional
edges just to make sure that you know
there is no two vertices vertices here
that have like high accuracy symptoms
so the effectiveness and diameter of
this graph by adding the star graph
that's just about it here change the
demand signal no
there's a lot of technical pieces here
are local and true whether but they are
but conceptual you know they are the
same yes this is just the way we do this
the conditioning and then once you do
that you can show by a profit argument
that you know now you'll never have
problems with with arcs that have large
SC so it's only you don't have to give
your problems are the arch with the
small move the small SC which you can
which you can deal with by just a chain
equality and in the end you know once
you add a couple of pages of work this
all comes together and gives you an
important button okay
so essentially this is all I want to say
about this result
okay so these are just a mechanism of
sort of moving this uh
okay instead of paying a lot uh you've
moved like you get some error and some
somewhere that you can fix later yes so
nice thing about this conversion is that
essentially once again these are artists
that do not exist in my original
distance so you know and the problem is
I think of course from the point of view
of the solution the sharks are you know
perfectly acceptable act so there is
some flow that will be routed over over
that and this is the flow that is
working like that is going over
phantomatics right so in the end I have
to deal with something to deal somehow
with this so what I have to run out this
flower this flows somehow and I just do
this and I only pay with Duality I'm
just showing the afternoon a number of
improvements that if I look at the flow
that that was drafted here and I just
you know route it back in a less
efficient way but you know this
increases by my majority Gap but then I
showed that my increasing my decrease in
Dubai is big enough that the small
increase well doesn't doesn't prevent my
in my profits but yes you have to deal
with it you have to specifically keep
track of the phone yes yes so that's the
moment when I said that the monster I
believe because you're removing this
edit and you see
okay so is it fair to say that the way
this algorithm pushes a lot of flow on
particular edges is by blowing up
resistance
what it is doing it's just yes it's
trying to like so what is the like the
big button like so one one nice problem
to think of when you try to get with a
maximum algorithm just to try to solve
the solution for the realization
okay and what is the problem when you
use energy card flows to do that the
problem is that you know there might be
one Edge that is so tempting for
electrical flows that they feel all the
like all the flow to it and that's a
useless social media because you know
you you would what you would like is
that if you have your
resistance message so I I assume all you
know how how we relax like how we can
capture wherever the magic is very much
snow so we are just trying to push
some flow from here to here
okay and the point is that you choose
what can happen at all the like flow of
like let's say you know that the magic
is exercise and so you prove you want to
push and like a value of and flows that
you know all of that does you know goes
over one or one R and this is useless to
you because you know how to like you
could just take a simple tough and push
what you really want to have is that you
know it's spread out among many among
many many different parts because that's
how you make a long triple progress in
in one step okay so essentially the
problem is of course I think I forgot to
know that and you can just still keep
some arcs to be you know to be more
desirable and then exactly you have the
stretching operation which is the
resistance to discourage the uh
what is the situation
okay
in the previous slide what did you mean
by increasing the length well I mean I
mean literally so you know like the
point is that when I I just want to
increase the proof okay we need to go
all the way around so
Arc
why you
why me
and somewhere here is the slack right
this is because so what I want to do I
want to add
because
SC to the cost
which ends up
unit costs it doesn't matter it's just
additive like I just like usually they
use but you know as you are stretching
things then the cost can grow so it's
whatever the the
credits yeah the actual course so I'm
changing the lp which is not ideal but
that's the best I can do but I have
instruction in reality not only my
solution but also
okay yeah
but for those
questions
were they important or they are
important so that's why I said that I
don't want this perturbation of course
to be too large because in the end I
want to be able to fix this capacity
between because sort of the statement
you can actually improve is that I can
solve any LP for you in this like M23 or
over 70 iterations the problem is that I
will solve not the lpu asked me so with
blp with some cost perturbation and for
Union capacity Max flow I can say
something about this you know like how
different is the solution to do this so
then I can fix it using automatic Buffs
for example I have no idea I don't know
like even changing one cost can increase
or you change the solution I don't know
how to fix it so I don't know how to do
this perturbation in a way that
preserves the
process of the prescription to the
actual Association
so there's augmenting fast is the thing
that moves analog in the same for
example I'll be okay the main thing or
the sort of
I'm not well yes but the question is
exactly like the point is in general you
can follow this is false right if I give
you a small L1 like if I have your the
course neurology and I just add this
small L1 like smaller normal
contribution to all the requirements to
the cost
foreign
capacities even one Arc might you know
like if it has a capacity of n is
suddenly a much bigger problem okay so
that's that's usually that's the only
way we're using capacity that's exactly
when in order to actually say something
about how much the perturbation hurts
so it's a roughly and also the major
encoding directions is that asymmetry is
that if you flow in the right direction
the stretch is small is not the wrong
direction the stretches yes but also
like some on some arcs you want to have
a good stretch and small and small
because you know the steps are supposed
to do one especially like some arcs you
don't want to route from the market they
should get life stress it's not only
granted today that's all of course what
will happen but again sometimes
sometimes the good directions exactly to
remove the flow because maybe that you
shouldn't be flowing the deployment
that's what it is yeah there are two
different reasons right
you know
okay I can tell you one more High
because I'm overtime but in this with a
little way of review
so that's that's all I want to say so
let me just you know as John said
participate and so you know what I
showed in this token
particularly that you know using
electrical flows for some type of
methods is a powerful new approach to to
Max Pro which makes a progress on things
that we want to get progressed and of
course the question is you know can we
go okay all the way can we get actually
an exact uh directed Max flow solid
engineer time my bed is yes and I think
I really think that you know we have the
critical mass of ideas but somehow well
it's not yet very good but I think we
are really confetti and in particular
you know it's
you know like I also want to just
retrace this point that I think it's
important to keep in mind during the
semester the one that James doesn't
agree with is that you know I view
electrical flows it's just the next
generation of spectral tools okay so
it's a good government Spectrum really
like to me okay whatever
so essentially
can you get something better using this
you know stronger tool like better grab
positioning and so on and of course were
there some answers about res there are
some ways there are some works that show
users that can flow and end up having
better guarantees than what is given by
everybody
but yeah and in particular we have seen
around the in the random directions
we are able to say something more about
behavioral model and Brazil how quickly
the the album mixes okay so so there are
some but of course I think this is just
the beginning and then of course you
know this is just a plugin because I'm a
graph here okay so I just want everyone
to think if you have some free time
during the semester it's just you know
there's so many problems in graph
algorithms you know can we get numeria
and algories for all and you know again
it's it's less a question of which
horror we want to solve it I think that
you know once we get enough tools and
enough ideas you know how to solve one
of the platforms
you will be able to adapt about it so I
really think that this is a challenge
because it's a great ambitious one but I
don't think it's as ridiculous at first
and in particular we have a newer like I
think recipe for for like I would say
under the problems when you just take
the three algebraic tools and could use
organizational methods and we just probe
the packaging all together and we get
something because we already have some
ideas now so do you really believe that
every crap no itemization of course I
don't know it's too motivate yes like I
don't know which one are and which I
don't know of course it's not true but
actually you know what you can say is
that there is a useful notion of
approximation
again this of course this is just a
slogan which as we know in life you
don't request them to reality but you
know
okay so in particular there is this M23
husband that shows up you know
everywhere and there is like quite a lot
of problems that got stuck on this
barrier and usually for similar reasons
so these are just you know some of them
and the questions you can we just take
this framework and just finally get rid
of this angle that you transformed and
put all the way
yeah okay in particular of course you
know I think the second order methods is
a new thing in the blog on the blog
because you know previously and this was
the right criticism was that okay well
this IPM so you have to take a little
set it's very expensive no that's not in
a way to get past algorithms but now we
see that in some cases important cases
we can solve like we've been taking
users faster and now you suddenly become
like with a very powerful camera there's
a lot of things that you can write as an
LP question is what can you do so that's
something to respond there and and
finally not just one one thing that I
also like about this about this I think
I also would like you to implement is
that okay so far you know we were using
when you look at optimization literature
we're using it as you know we were using
someone okay so we're just taking you
know this we are taking that and
plugging into our Progressive but now I
really genuinely believe that you cannot
contribute that okay but you can just
see
and that that you know but some of the
ideas that come up in the specific
application of this tools end up being
the applicable model broadly so in
particular you know one thing that
essentially you can prove is that even
though you know I had this interpreted
in this video for a particular you know
Max flow question in general what it
really tells us is that you know as I
already said you can solve any LP faster
except this will not be there IP you ask
for okay so that's not ideal yet but you
know maybe it's getting them together
there are some ideas that I think are
important it might be even new to the to
the to the optimization
I think people should realize so you
know one thing is the interview
but you really have to look at all four
Norm if you want to have progress if you
look at them also known guys no hope for
Progress at all the other thing is
exactly like something that I didn't say
especially but what we were doing when
you prepared hours of our problem we are
also preparing this to help
it doesn't matter you know which Central
path you're following as long as it gets
you to Optimum so what we were doing and
I didn't really highlight this but this
is what is happening behind like under
the hood is that whenever we don't like
our Central Power we are perturbing it
to get something better okay so
essentially we're changing ourselves
back up whenever we don't like it and
that's I think another thing something
that that and also the other thing
that's important is that if you ask and
that's one of the barriers where we are
stuck at square root of M for General
okay if you ask me you know you are
someone else and you want to take a step
better
but the whole point was they're showing
that okay Sometimes some steps are bad
but then our sources are good and
someone hiding the non-local competitive
allies which again is happening in
somewhere in some papers but not really
in that muscle I think people are trying
to understand like there's this kind of
you know this kind of understanding of
the questions you know if you look like
always like a lower bound to the side of
the step work you know until about
setting which is not impossible
barrier naturally there is a very
exciting recent War by this effort who
are here and then in Cycles well
actually they they also you know they
also use some of the ideas from here but
also other very interesting ideas from
there at a separate they get an
improvement like very important
improvement over over this band they get
the iteration advantages as a rank of
the Matrix of this constraint Matrix to
one half so the rank is always at most n
but sometimes it's smaller in particular
by using literally that's exactly how
they got this result when they get
better sparsity for the for the Maxwell
they went especially from m to the three
halves to n Square
okay and that's exactly this is no this
is exactly the side of what they
captured differently
okay
so yeah and you know I you already have
that from from God I guess I don't have
to and I don't think I have to like you
know explain like sort of a confusion
again that's really it's really
important to try to combine commentary
around and and and yeah I think that
there is a there is a rule for computing
that actually where they have seen some
examples when I heard but it's really
easy and design execution is sure okay
thank you
all right so uh so uh Spielman also were
able to get in the same time in cost Max
flow yes can you do men cause matching
no better no like the problem is that
you know it was there's a few problems
okay I didn't think about me because
marching actually like the problem is
that still whatever you use this is
so this is a bit I would need to think
so I'm not sure definitely for being
cosmetics
for me because matching I think also I
can do it but I would need to think why
like one problem that you are having
speculation in cost which might be much
more significant when the costs are
deterred because maybe sometimes are
very small and when you add some fixed
fixed additive additive factor to it we
will add to it they will come completely
that's going to change the big crazy
product but okay definitely don't claim
I can maybe I can but I probably skip it
quite a lot
of tradition where you can become the
speaker with extra questions
thanks very much